we've seen the alt-right just pray at
the altar of Trump for the economic
success that they saw through the run-up
in the stock market since Donald Trump
was elected president of the United
States and now that we have seen the
biggest single-day decline in the Dow
Jones Industrial Average on a point
basis they are saying not well maybe we
were wrong about Trump they are saying
is this not a false flag meant to hurt
Donald Trump politically conspiracy
theorists and scams supplement salesmen
Alex Jones tweeted as this was happening
is the historic 1500 point Dow drop a
false flag by the big banks should we
investigate Goldman Sachs it's kind of
funny to mention Goldman Sachs because
Trump's administration is filled with
Goldman Sachs people why why would you
investigate then they're on Trump's team
is the idea that the people on Trump's
team from Goldman Sachs are involved in
crashing the stock market yeah you got
Gary Cohen the chief economic adviser
and Steve my nutrient the Treasury
secretary and you're probably happy boys
probably also some lower echelon people
as well that we don't even know right
it's it's unlikely those are the only
two Goldman people that Trump is hired
this is sort of like gas prices right
either the president is responsible for
both the ups and the downs or for
neither but you can't have it both ways
and the horrible part is people fall for
this drivel the real tragedy is that
there is a significant portion of the
followers of Alex Jones and if Donald
Trump and whoever else who fall for this
stuff and there actually is a real
conspiracy theory here it's the one that
unregulated capitalism is sort of a
pyramid scheme that redistributes wealth
from the poor to the rich that's the
real conspiracy here the Oleg arca code
kleptocratic conspiracy theory they
never talk about that one but this one
they believe and if you look at some of
the responses to Alex Jones tweets
people are eating this stuff up like it
is real one example yes I thought as
much
thanks Alex for being one of the few
voices
reporting the truth another person on
Twitter who really liked this from Alex
Jones I agree is this the deep state our
government retaliation against Trump may
sound crazy that that's right it does
but what can we believe nowadays I won't
show you too many more of these they
make me a little sick to my stomach
actually it would be easier to write
this stuff off as a joke but when you
see that it influences so many people
we've got to address it in some way but
the problem that that exists is the
people who believe this stuff also
believe that they will be told it's not
true and that that's part of the
conspiracy so if you go to them and you
say hey hold on a second here's a reason
why this doesn't make sense
here's another reason why this does it
doesn't make sense they will say that's
part of the conspiracy those talking
points are part of the conspiracy so
it's a closed loop it said there's Doc's
a stick closure to take a phrase from
Peter Boghossian and I don't know how we
should be handling this yeah and
whatever Alex Jones says is gospel to
them - they won't course agree and Alex
Jones has tied himself to Donald Trump
at this point he says that he calls
Trump from time to time oh sure even
last month he made a phone call to the
White House you believe that I don't
know I mean like you're dealing with the
word of Trump versus Alex Jones right I
tend to believe it uh Trump in that
scenario is I don't know that's a tough
one if you've got alex jones and donald
trump explaining to you what it is that
you need to do to save humanity i don't
know who you listen to I really don't so
anyway I know most people in our
audience don't fall for this stuff but
there are people who do and I do think
it's important to point it out send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show and we've got one heck of a program
for you today today's episode of the
David Pakman show is made possible in
part by brilliant which is a really
fantastic and unique online service that
has sort of reinvented the way people
learn math and science if you watch the
David Pakman show you're probably a
person who's curious about how the world
works and loves to learn new things
maybe you have a casual interest
in areas like physics or solar energy AI
philosophy computer science but you're
ready to take that knowledge that
learning to the next level and whether
you already have a grasp on these
subjects or you're looking for a fun and
engaging way to become acquainted with
them for the first time brilliant really
is the place to go where you can
actually learn hands-on by solving
problems and puzzles that were designed
by expert educators and professionals
and you can get started right now by
signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman and the first 200
people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman will get 20% off an annual
premium membership that's brilliant org
forward slash David Pakman